the house ways and means committee i
find that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor
as a republican 19 pandemic and
according to the hospital 67 and the
governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to executive order
2020 04 this
public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a revenue work session please
note that there is no physical location
for members of the public to observe and
listen contemporariously to this meeting
however according to the emergency order
i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaries during this
meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaries
listen and if necessary participate in
this meeting
by the zoom platform by telephone
all necessary information has been made
available in the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notices for this meetings complies
with the house rules
and rsa 91a anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should call 271
3600 or
email hcs leg.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting assisting us
chris uh jennifer floor
researcher please note that all votes
that are taken during this meeting
should be done by roll call bill
let's start the meeting by taking up all
call of attendance when each member
states their presence please also state
whether there is
anyone in the room whether you're doing
this meeting which is required under the
right to know law
thank you mr chair and good morning to
you sir today is may 25th
2021 it's 10 a.m we'll begin roll call
with representative abrami
here in my home in stratham and i'm
alone representative griffin
representative ovary home
alone well the wife is in the house
someplace hudson
representative ober ohman hudson the
outside temperature is 80
you still look like a cool cat there
representative
representative doucette uh good morning
my home alarm
your clerk is alan berschke and i'm in
my home office by myself in nottingham
new hampshire
representative bob elliott here
alone in salem new hampshire
representative genigion here alone in my
salem new hampshire
office representative nunes
actually representative nunes texted me
saying he'll be
in labor today so i texted him back
saying i hope it's a boy
don't give up your day job ellen
representative baxter
representative tudor here in the
sullivan northwood wife and grandkids
upstairs
representative here in lebanon alone
representative ames i'm here in jeffrey
in my home office alone
representative southwood here in dover
represent the honorable representative
good morning i am present and alone
representative
phillips good morning i too am present
and alone
representative murphy good morning i am
home alone in hanover
chairman representative norman major
good morning i'm in my home in palasto
and my wife is in the house and
hopefully the maintenance person will be
here soon
mr chair there are 17 members present
and my guess
is the other seven members are at the
thank you representative branson janine
uh okay you have let and
melissa devin and carolyn
i had scheduled thursday
in case we needed and we will not be
meeting thursday
the main reason is that chris is tied up
with the senate and he will be tied up
with the senate for a while
i asked if he would be available on
tuesday
next week not being available there
our next meeting on schedule for tuesday
the 8th
of june at 10 o'clock for our renters
so no meeting scheduled for next week
the next meeting is the 8th of june
the email that i sent out
relative to the bills that are going to
be
passed at our sessions
days next week was primarily
in case those that are on the consent
calendar are pulled off
and somebody signs up if they don't
nobody will be speaking and then on
those that are on the regular calendar
uh if there's nobody signed up in
opposition
there'll be nobody speaking
we'll be we'll be hearing from the
department of revenue
and they're primarily going over the
revenues that they had
worked with the senate on these so these
will be the updated revenues
so everybody was sent a 10 page document
last night if you don't have it
it will be coming up on the screen and
you can follow through with that
all right so i'll turn this over to
carolyn
melissa and devin so caroline
you're muted thank you good morning mr
chair and members of the committee
for the record melissa rollins senior
financial analyst for the department of
revenue
and with me for some support is carolyn
lear assistant commissioner
would you mind if i shared my screen to
show the presentation that you had just
mentioned
that would be super okay perfect one
second
she'll be able to do that right good you
have
okay so everyone can see that
perfect okay welcome
um so yes representative major as you
had said
today we are going to speak about
revenue estimates that we have
updated uh we did this present
presentation to senate ways and means
may 10th um and had worked with them
as they just finalized their revenue
estimates which are at the end of our
presentation for cons comparison
purposes
uh the layout is very similar to what
you have seen in the past we will go
through all our major taxes
and show you the adjustments compared to
plan as well as letting you know that
this data is through
april as we are wrapping up may now but
i can speak to may some
and to let you know that we did take
into account obviously
the uh possible changes in recovery
effects of covid19
so below is the chart that you're
typical typically used of seeing
we have our dra taxes we have plan for
fiscal year 21
we have the anomalous receivable that
we've spoke about several times so i
won't go over that
um if you have questions feel free to
ask but i think you're pretty familiar
with that
we have our low and high which is net of
that anomalous receivable
which is again consistent with how we've
done it in the past
and then we have two columns we have our
low
compared to plan and our high compared
to plan
i do want to know a couple of the taxes
have not changed since we were back here
a month ago i think it was april 28th
that's meals and rentals cst and revenue
uh excuse me real estate transfer tax
those taxes performed as we had expected
so we did not update
our estimates for the year i also want
to note that
our growth ranges also have not changed
uh
for the taxes we hadn't had any
additional information since april 28th
to to make any modifications to those
and lastly as you're familiar with we i
did want to note that as you can see
in our revenue estimates on the far
right-hand side
covet has affected taxes very
differently
we do know some taxes have been
performing very well
like business taxes and tobacco taxes
where m r has been hit the hardest but
if you've been following either
crochet's
revenue updates or the revenue updates
that devin sends out you can see that m
r actually
okay moving on to business taxes
i think when we came april 29th our
april 28th
last month we hadn't updated these yet
we wanted to see how april had performed
before we made
estimates for the remaining uh months
so i'm sure you have looked at the
information and have seen
that april was a really healthy
april is a really healthy month um
business taxes
for the month of april were 47.5
or 73.8 million ahead of plan and that
was our largest
april looking back the last 10 years
uh fiscal year to date we're 174.5
million or 27.5
ahead of plan that does include that
18.3 million dollar anomalous receivable
and then we're 252 or 45.4
ahead of prior year uh as we know this
pandemic it's had different impacts on
businesses
with some hurting while others were
thriving
based on the revenue it does look like
business activity for april
performed much better than we
anticipated as well as i believe
businesses anticipated and i say that
because we do know
businesses some businesses definitely
struggled and suffered through the
pandemic
however it appears that the majority of
new hampshire business taxpayers
did fare better than they had expected
and this is shown in part again to april
being up that 73.8 million
meaning um and it was driven by the
extension payments meaning that
taxpayers didn't
adjust their estimate payments through
the year
and then when they had to true up their
payment come march and april
uh they ended up paying a lot more than
they had anticipated paying
and we think this can be in part with
businesses and individuals receiving
more money from the state and federal
federally than they expected we've had
lots of talks about it and we know that
this was the largest stimulus package
the federal government has ever
infused in the economy with being a
little a little bit less than 25
of gdp and then this coupled with
consumers having more money spending
more money to spend and a shift in the
economy had
businesses reporting higher profits than
so because of how much in april came
we revised our revenue estimates and
used a different modeling approach
what we did was look at historic
performance
and how that was based on march and
april's performance
so we modeled our low estimate
for fiscal year 21 947.5 million
was based on the low historical
performance of
may and june based on march and april
and then our high
revenue was 964.9 million
and that was modeled aft as the average
historic performance of revenue for may
and june
based on march and april and then for
our fiscal year 22 and 23 growth rates
you should be familiar with these at
this point
um we have a two to six percent
on predicted gdp for
fiscal year 22 and then for fiscal year
23 we have a three to five
percent um growth rate based on gdp as
well
well not so you didn't change the growth
rates
and so these are based upon which
growth rates that you would have seen
we adjusted these i think a couple
months back
okay all right so soon enough
happy to answer any questions on
business taxes
representative romney followed by
representative and
representative thank you mr chair rob
thanks melissa
so i just want to make sure i understand
so the
you didn't you didn't adjust 21. 21 is
what it is even though we know some of
that money that's come in may have to be
given back next year correct
right so just just to inform the
committee
the way the revenue estimates work is
it's based on current law
and um if there are any dollars going
back based on bills for instance like
sb3 those come out in the surplus
statement item
so we don't adjust for those revenues
coming out of the taxes again it's based
on base
and then chris will do up the surplus
statement to get the net revenue
okay yes that's that's what i assume
we're going to do is that we'll uh
we'll do our but this is the base even
though we know the base is kind of
it could be potentially higher than it
should be
but that's the only way we can show it
uh and then it's really us
up to us to determine how much anomalous
revenue in the next two years uh
or uh that would we'd show in the uh
surplus statement
as a negative correct is that what we're
going to do
yes okay thank you representative
and i had the same kind of question
i mean this this is really anomalous
this revenue
increase but i guess we can't treat it
as anomalous until
that's the first time we run into this
problem
thank you mr chair um let's see if i can
inquire now you're you're low range
in high range two to six does that take
into effect
the likely increase in federal taxes
that are being considered at least or is
that just
strictly keeping things the way they are
so this is um keeping things the way
they are however and
caroline jump in here if i'm incorrect
in speaking
but i do know that if federal taxes
are increased i don't think that should
affect our revenue as it doesn't affect
the base of taxpayers
i think it only affects our revenue if
even though they would be spending more
money off the top and
having less money for us
okay yeah that would come up in another
area okay yeah yeah
thank you um yeah i hear the same i'm
puzzling over the same question that
representative abrami and representative
alan
put to the fore and uh
um it seems to you built uh dra has
built its
uh its estimate for the
next fiscal year and the year just the
year after that
on this fiscal year's
fiscal year 21's performance as i
understand it less
without the anomalies that we've been
with sb3
assuming that passes there'll be a
surplus statement that says
presumably you'd use your timing
methodology
somewhere in the neighborhood of 45 or
50 million dollars
um which suggests that
in these figures that are for fy21
there's an anomalous amount
that shouldn't be part of the growth
projection and
sure i will uh take a stab at that
question so i think
there's two different issues here we
have sb3
right that will be coming out on the
surplus statement
and then we just have ppp loans in
general and what they produce for
revenue so i think those are two
separate items so sb3
is revenue the 90 99.4 million spread
out over the years
is coming out because the ppp is not
included in the gross income
and then they still get the deduction so
they're essentially getting
those extra funds back or those extra
funds
as a deduction against non-ppp
so that revenue is accounted for in the
surplus statement
however if sb3 if we were just at
current law without
sp3 in i don't think we think ppp
would increase revenue a tremendous
amount
because as carolyn has has spoke to that
if ppp is in their income and then if
they use
that ppp as a deductible expense which
we assume most of them will
there is not a large revenue impact of
okay thank you before we go to
representative alame
uh there's one thing that nobody's
mentioned yet
besides the ppp there's
in these revenues that we're seeing now
that are higher than we was predicted
as a result of the other type of
stimuluses
that have been going on and
we haven't been able to identify those
yet
but has caused some of this
excess revenue and
that isn't going to continue
so we need to be able to
if not now define how much of that
extra revenue is associated with those
other types of stimulus packages
have you done any of that yet melissa
so i think as carolyn has spoke to and
we spoke to a couple of times the
challenge is is that when we get returns
i mean first off we know the issue is
that there's been an increase in
extensions so we don't have the data
there second the data that does come in
the money flows onto one line of the
return and it doesn't break out where
those funds have come
from so it's near impossible for us to
say
what has increased those funds and if
that those trends will continue over
the years this has been a very dynamic
economy where
businesses have shifted in and
really have has a lot of them have done
well during this pandem
pandemic with the help of these stimulus
funds
and maybe that bolstered their business
enough it's hard to say
whether that is going to be one time and
then you're going to see a drop
or if they've both these funds have
bolstered their business enough
and improved made improvements that
these revenues will continue
it's definitely an area that could use
some discussion
i don't think we have the data or
information to say where that has fallen
except looking at gdp and it doesn't
look like that's predicted to decline
so they're expecting the economy to
right and the gdp latest
information i heard for 2021
it's supposed to come out to be in the
six
so that gdp it would be nice if it could
stay at six percent but i doubt it
uh representative almighty followed by
representative romney
thank you mr chairman it's uh
this is going to be really difficult but
on
the first thing on i wanted to say
ask was on after we pass
sb 3 on
if when we do another revenue estimate
the revenue that we can identify which i
guess isn't going to be at least until
after
october on that is due to
sb3 be treated as anomalous
and even though it's in the surplus
statement for the budget
on and
i'm the other thing talking about
the continued stimulus that
is going on uh a lot of it is supposed
to be directed towards
infrastructure kinds of things capital
investment
on but also they
fashioned that bill trying to help
the what they think of as smaller
businesses
and that's another problem for the
for us those are probably the large
businesses uh the top ones
uh to the extent that they send that
stimulus
more to small real businesses we call
smaller medium on we haven't been
i don't know if that's going to reduce
the amount of revenue we get
or if they're going to thrive which
would be nice
but this whole thing
your response melissa sure i tend to
agree with you representative almi it is
murky
for sure um obviously i've said it
before we we haven't been through
anything like this so
modeling it out and and trying to see
what's going to happen
is an evolution for sure um
to go back to your original question
about sb3
and when that passes in revenue so i can
just give you some information on how
plan is built so when plan
is built it's based on the revenues that
is
agreed upon the final revenues are done
and then surplus statement is subtracted
out of those base revenues
and that would be the same for fiscal
year 22 and 23 so essentially revenue
estimates base which are agreed upon
and finalized and then subtracting out
what's in the surplus statement so sb3
would be on that surplus statement for
22 and 23 and that would be the
representative romney i'm going to beat
this to death here a bit
um so for us to try to figure out
you know we may need to do an adjustment
to the base year revenues
just on paper as we project 22 and 23
and and to me it's not the full 99.4
million
it's something less than that that was
i would consider anomalous because they
paid
you know hoping sp3 would pass but
knowing that they were going to get
refunds
so but so i
do we have an idea of what for santa
we've i think we've asked this we had
this discussion before
do we know or a good guess at
uh what percentage of the 99.4 million
came
in in that we're going to give back
came in in march and april as people
were filing
their taxes so
we have looked at it and i i want to
again separate out sb3 and just say what
percentage of revenue came in
for taxpayers who paid or filed a
schedule for which is where the ppp data
is reported on
and that was about 5.4 million
that came in in march and april so again
those taxpayers actually physically
filed the return and had the schedules
that
that reported the ppp data um
the loans were forgiven and all that
correct correct
i'm sorry keep on going um and again i'm
going to have carolyn has been the sp3
expert i'll speak to it but if i say
anything
she could feel free to jump and
incorrect again i think
that 99 million is
how do i want to term it it's funds that
would not have come in through the
revenue some portion
that their profit exceeded their
deduction would be paying revenue
but i think we believe for the majority
of taxpayers
in the ppp area if they paid
if their loan was forgiven for ppp and
they had
expenses if they expensed it out
there would be no tax revenue impact the
reason there is a revenue impact
for sb3 is because
you no longer have that ppp data
in the income line and you have extra
expenses now to offset
revenue without that ppp so it's a it's
a
added benefit as to why
there's a reef um a revenue expense of
the 99.4 million
because of that added benefit of the sb3
or the pvp not being included in the
income
okay like others have said this is this
gets more confusing as we talk
so it's okay i think we'll come up with
something i'm sure
any further questions before melissa
okay so moving on to meals and rentals
tax as i stated in the beginning
we haven't updated our projections for
meals and rentals tax because it has
fallen
in line the last couple of months of how
we anticipated
uh fiscal year to date we are 64.9
million
or 19.8 percent below plan
that's through april um or 35.5 million
or 11.9 percent below prior year
uh we do know if again if those of you
have been following the report that
m r um so far is 2.9 percent below plan
which is a
a pretty big increase and we know this
based
um partly of things opening back up more
people being
vaccinated higher consumer confidence
and then just as this recovery rate
continues to
to perform as we enter these warm months
i would suggest
on meals and rentals tax when you're
doing your revenue estimates we do have
this range of 315.4 million as our low
in 320 0.4 million as our high
to probably lean towards the higher end
as may came in
towards our higher end of revenue
estimates and i don't think that's going
to fall backwards
so i think the 315.4 is probably low at
this point and would
would recommend you guys going towards
our higher end
our higher end assumes a faster
improvement um
and that's that's exactly what we've
seen this month and then for fiscal year
22 and 23 we have the five to
five to ten percent growth um
which is equal to 2018 revenues and the
highs equal to 2019 revenue sort of
getting us
back to the normal range and then fiscal
year 23 is four to six percent
which is back to the historical um
growth that we've seen in the past for m
r
any questions on meals and rentals tax
questions
uh representative selfless
uh thank you this has been an area i've
been thinking about for quite a while
and just two anecdotes i just want to
see if they fit in
my local everyday restaurant put 10
tables outside
but now the outside tables are full and
they're full inside and they hired two
new weight people
also a gourmet restaurant that was very
hard to get into
and was losing funds um started letting
people do
ten parties could do gourmet takeout at
two o'clock
and they would stagger those now they're
fully open inside
they're still doing the ten party
takeout and again
they're doing better than ever even
though they're having to make up for the
past so
that's just a couple examples in my area
yeah i think that probably falls in line
with why the growth
vaccination
okay melissa all right tobacco tax
um we did revise this tax tobacco tax
fiscal year to date
were 40.4 million or 24.4 percent ahead
of plan
and 34.3 or 20 ahead of prior year
as we've talked about quite a bit
the massachusetts ban on ventilated
tobacco and other flavored tobacco
products has continued to drive this
increase
in revenues and other states have also
seen that trend
what we are keeping an eye on for future
tax years
is there has been a uh the fda has been
speaking about a proposed national black
band on flavored tobacco products so
just something to
to keep in mind there's no updated
information um as of yet i think that
came out at the end of april
and i asked the question right now is
that
um do you know how much
of this revenue is due to the
methanol cigarettes
so we don't have a breakdown of that
it's not reported on
our return uh so it would
it would be pretty difficult for us to
say what the impact would be if there is
a ban on flavor tobacco products however
we do
know that this is the increase is driven
by those mentholated prop
um mentholated tobacco products
anecdotally we had reached out to
wholesalers and retailers
in the border states and they had
confirmed that they had seen
quite dramatic increase in mentholated
in flavor tobacco products but we don't
have a breakdown on that
in our return data all right thank you
do you want representative berstein or
do you want to keep going
representative bernstein has his hand up
thank you mr chair
thanks for taking my question man listen
there was some um
legislation in the mass house about
repealing
the prohibition on um menthol cigarettes
menthol products do you have any idea
where that legislation stands now did
that
get defeated or uh and i guess that's
not just to you but
anyone who has any knowledge on it sure
i did see that
and we do get regular updates on
legislative
um information for tobacco i don't think
last i knew it was going to pass
i don't think it had very strong legs
but i don't have an update we can look
into that if you'd like just to confirm
that
it hasn't had any gain traction since i
last saw information on it
thank you that would be good if you
looked into that thanks anybody else
questions on tobacco at this point
go ahead and go awesome okay so our
low is 245.6 million
this assumes the increase due to
massachusetts flavor ban continues at
the consistent rate
and then our high is 248.3 million
and this assumes the fiscal year to date
over plan of 24
is maintained um
for the rest of the year as well as an
increase with the cross-border sales
due to consumer confidence again and
travel restrictions lifted
and then for fiscal year 22 we have
negative
three percent to zero percent um this is
the historic year-over-year reduction
and then we tempered it to account for
any residual offsetting of e-cigarettes
um and then fiscal year 23
we have a negative four percent to
negative one percent
and again that's just consistent with
tobacco tax trends
um in the past after we sort of had this
year of
uh this blip year of um
the e-cigarettes and the massachusetts
tobacco
happy to answer questions on tobacco
is minus three percent enough if they
ban
flavored tobacco if they take the banana
off of
flavored tobacco products in
can you ask that one more time do you
mean if they put the band
on in massachusetts oh yeah if they put
it on right
sorry that's okay too many negatives
didn't i thought
that's okay um so we have not accounted
for
the national ban on flavored tobacco
products because we don't know if it's
going through at this point
um i did read that if it were to go
through it would take a year
so i assume we'd see it more in 23 than
but it's not factored into our estimates
go ahead melissa
all right moving on to interest and
dividends tax i think when we were here
a month ago we didn't have
we didn't have an estimate on this tax
because we were waiting for april to
come in
uh fiscal year to date we are 13.5
million
or 13.8 percent ahead of plan this
includes the 9.2 million of us anomalous
receivable
and we're 33.8 or 43.7 ahead of prior
year
as we know this tax does have historic
year-over-year swings
and does seem to do well when the stock
market
performs well which is shaky a little
here and there
right now we do know people have had
more money in the bank during
this pandemic lastly i want to know
wanted to note that the irs did extend
the due date for individuals to pay
returns to may 17th
although new hampshire maintained their
april 15th due date
so in april we did see some reductions
in revenues and we assumed
it was because of the federal due date
as
um we talked about the anomalous
receivable that happened
when taxpayers did that last year when
the uh feds put the due date out to july
and we said june taxpayers still filed
late so
looking at main numbers so far they have
come in
uh ahead of plan and that is because
taxpayers filed late they were supposed
to
file it in april and they filed in may
based on the federal due date
we did factor that into our revenue
estimates
so fiscal year 21 our low range is 124
million
this assumes fiscal year to date
percentage over plan of 14
is maintained through the end of the
year um with
revenue shifting again from april to may
and then our high is 132 point million
this again assumes revenue shifted from
april to may
with increased tax reported on returns
and extensions for texture 20 compared
to 2019
and 2021 estimates continuing on trend
it looks like right now based on our
estimates it's
we still have june to come in which is
another estimate month but we're falling
pretty close to the middle of our range
right now for
interest and dividends tax for fiscal
year 21.
and then fiscal year 22 we have the four
to six percent growth based on past
performance of the tax
coupled with anticipated gdp
and then in 23 we have this tax slowing
down to a two to four percent growth
again based on past performance and then
an anticipated reduction of gdp
in 2023
once more any questions on interest and
dividend tax uh represent
southwest uh yes
basically this would be deducted in the
surplus station
statement if various bills pass that's
accurate
so it would be you know a net zero
really
the what would be a net zero well if
it goes in in the revenue and comes out
in the surplus statement
if it's phased out quickly and we don't
know how that's going to work but
yeah so i think that the phase out the
the larger impact is in later years it's
a longer phase out for this tax so i
think there's sort of a minimal in
a minimal decrease that will occur on
the surplus statement for 22 and 23 and
then the further you go out the larger
the decrease will be
in revenues so pardon my
ignorance so really they have decided
that they're going to do the face out
it's i think it's still up for
discussion it's over um with the senate
thank you mr chairman um i'm not sure
um you're gonna know the answer to this
uh melissa but
i guess one of the things i'm concerned
about is we've heard that the biden
administration
is considering doubling the capital
gains tax
so that instead of the high range of 20
it'll be
potentially high range of 40 plus yield
obama tax of 3.4
yielding a total capital gains of
roughly i believe
it's 43.4 or something like that
do we have any historical data on how
tax received could be influenced by the
federal i know it's
the federal has been the same for quite
some time so that's why i'm
wondering whether you have any idea how
that could influence because that's
going to be a huge change in the federal
which could cause people to not
you know sell stocks and other things
um we have not done any comparison
from the interest and dividends tax to
the federal tax
uh carolyn do you have any more
information on how you think
that would affect interest and dividends
tax
no i don't have any other information
but i do think it's an apt
point right i mean the tax rate
certainly could impact taxpayer behavior
and therefore impact our tax
of course the ind tax doesn't tax
capital gains
it cap it uh taxes the
income earned on holding stock so if the
federal
tax rate encourages taxpayers to hold on
to their stock longer rather than
sell it presumably you could see an
impact on the ind tax which i'm
presuming
would be a positive impact um
but i don't know that we've we've
certainly not looked at it before and i
would have to think
long and hard about whether we could do
any predictive work
to try to estimate that impact
yeah i just uh thank you i i believe
that that capital gains
tax proposal is uh
related only to taxpayers with very high
incomes
in other words there's a different
threshold
this part of the package so
just take that into account um and then
of course the other point is that
uh that as far as individuals are
concerned we don't tax
capital gains and
perhaps the buying and selling of stock
would be triggered by
the federal action but as
i say it's limited to some individuals
who have other ways of making their
money
and uh so i'm not so sure that would be
the case
further questions or comments on the
okay melissa you can continue okay
um moving on to cst or the communication
services tax this is again a tax that we
have not
um felt the need to update since we last
presented to you because it's ahead
performed as we anticipated
fiscal year to date through april um or
a hundred million or
point three percent below plan so
basically at plan
and um four hundred thousand or one
point two percent ahead of prior year
this tax can be affected by the new
hampshire unemployment rate
taxability of video conferencing and the
increased use of product as well as
decreased use of voip
so as i said our estimate has remained
the same at 39.1 million
this is a loss of 2 for the remaining
months of the year
and then we keep this tax flat for
22 and 23.
it's a pretty consistent tax month over
can you speak more to the taxability of
sure so i think we're still at the same
point that we discussed
a month ago if if that's what you're
referring to
when we say taxability video
conferencing we're talking about some
applications like we're using today
those are taxable under the
communication services tax and obviously
have been
in higher demand and higher use since
the pandemic
our audit division is working on making
sure taxpayers are paying taxes
and hopefully we'll make sure everyone's
in compliance
you seen much evidence
of a number
of clients not compliance on this
video conferencing tax
i think again it's a little bit too
early to know that audit is doing a
project on it
um so they will eventually have more
information if they can share it based
on the number of taxpayers but
um when they file the return it's not
broken out onto
what area is being taxed it's just a
number as a whole so it takes some
digging to see
if they are charging tax on it
well that's a statement that comes up
all the time doesn't it
sure does oh representatives you still
have your hand
up no no i'm sorry
uh any further questions on the
okay melissa okay real estate transfer
tax again this is a tax we did not
update our estimate from when we were
last here because
it had performed as we expected in april
and in may
i think we're starting to figure out a
little bit which is nice uh fiscal year
to date
we through april were 37 million or
or 28.2 ahead of plan and 30.2 million
or 21.9
ahead of prior year as we've stated
several times
fiscal year to date amounts are net of a
5 million transfer to the affordable
housing fund
it's new this year so when you're
comparing it to prior year
you should add back that five million um
to get sort of an apples to apples
comparison
with real estate transfer tax um it's
important to look at mortgage interest
interest rates in how they're performing
they have been at a historical low we do
know that they've bumped
up in the last month or so not by a ton
but something
definitely keeping an eye on other
factors are virtual home
sales and available housing and property
value
as well as inventory shortage cost of
building supplies
and a lower affordability factor so we
know
all of these really make this this tax
go
up and down so we know that home prices
have gone
through the roof especially with
available housing
being low people are paying much more
for homes and actually paying cash for
homes
than they had in the past however there
what we do
keep an eye on is that affordability
factor because
if you have high home prices and low
interest rates you can afford more but
if those interest rates start to go
up and home prices keep going up what
someone can afford definitely decreases
and that can affect the amount of
transactions that occur
so for fiscal year 21 we have a range of
201.5 million
this assumes the fiscal year to date
percentage over plan of 28
is maintained through the end of the
year and our tie is 205.7 million
and this assumes the fiscal year date
percentage over plan increases to 30
percent
for fiscal year 22 we have a low
of negative seven percent and a high of
a negative two percent
the negative seven percent assumes that
the fiscal year is going to continue
strong and then it's slowly going to
taper off to performance less than we
and that's for the negative seven to
negative two percent and then fiscal
year 23 we have a range of negative 10
percent to negative 8
again we assume historical trends were
maintained
for fiscal year 2020 through 2022 so
essentially removing this
this um peak that we have seen with real
estate transfer tax
and the spike in the housing market and
that does fall in line with the
economist predictions that 2023 will
start to
um have a lower decline compared to 22
representative thank you mr chairman
um i was just wondering when you
estimate your ranges
um do you take potential inflation into
account
as there is a concern that inflation may
increase
um in the next in the coming years
is inflation part i guess is the
inflation factor a part of the
range uh we have not specifically looked
at inflation and applying it to our
estimate ranges
so the fy23
it's more so that the housing bubble is
coming down
because the interest rates are going up
less houses are sold and prices are
probably
is that the main contributor yeah i the
way we modeled out fiscal year 23
is we took 21 out of the picture
so where would we be if we started um
with 20 and if we continued to grow
because real estate transfer has a
pretty
standard growth rate over the last
couple of years so if you took that
standard growth rate from fiscal year 20
and grew it to fiscal year 23 what would
that look like
and that brought us to that negative 10
to negative 8
because we don't think that the market
will maintain where it has been with the
spike up with all the factors that have
come in with again the real estate
market being um really hot interest
rates being really low
and what has happened is i'm sure you've
all read in the news is that the
inventory shortage have shrunk as well
as cost of building supplies
and getting people to build homes has
also reduced so that
inventory is starting to fall at
historical lows
um so at some point we think it's going
to catch up
and um not have enough
housing available which would decrease
decrease the home prices as well as
decrease the transaction amounts and get
us back to the normal
any further questions uh representative
brownlee
yeah thank you mr chair uh listen this
is a random thought i had here as you're
talking
you know we all we all look at that
revenue focus at the end of
every month um and that's put out by
administrative services
that puts that out administrative
services
yep uh but
i think you guys do you guys provide
input
into how to spread how to spread the
revenues
uh especially in a year that may be
different than
past years like this tax for instance
may have a different pattern of uh
uh you know because you were saying you
know if
by the by the second half of the year
the number of transactions would be less
than
uh then the first half of the year which
may be different than
the historic trends so do you get to say
your piece
does department of revenue get to work
with them to
come up with the way to spread the
estimates across the 12 months
yeah great question representative brown
we sure do so
essentially das sends us our revenues
and asks that asks us to
spread them out over the 12 months and
we do look at information like that we
look at historical trends we look at how
it performed the prior year
we remove any anomalies that we know
occurred in different months that may
spike up a percentage of revenue in a
specific month
and then we may also make adjustments to
situations like this where
where we may see a spike up in the first
six months and then a decrease in the
next six months
and then we submit that to das for
approval okay that's good to know thank
you
all right i believe this is our last tax
utility property tax
um we did adjust this down some fiscal
year to date
through april we're down 2.6 million or
7.8 percent below plan
and 1.8 million or 5.6 below
prior year um we did want to note that
in april we did see a decline in revenue
compared to prior year
in plan and this was essentially due to
some credits on file
and due to decreased valuations compared
to prior years
so we have the next month being down at
and that is because valuations that came
in in january
were down 10 compared to the prior year
and just a little bit information for
those of you that are not familiar how
upt
works essentially taxpayers make
quarterly estimate payments based on
their last valuation
and then in january they true up those
payments compared to their new
assessment value
so if they paid if their assessment
value went more they end up with more
funds
on file which essentially creates a
credit and then they
use those up pretty quick and that's
what we saw in april some utilization of
those credits
uh other factors to consider with this
tax is some
property properties may decline in value
due to changes in economic conditions
or may uh sometimes get adjusted if
there's new taxable
property that may be constructed and it
does appear that upt
was not impacted by the coven 19
economic crisis
with that information fiscal year 21
our new number is 40.6 million
and then again we have the tax slat for
22 and 23.
okay melissa continue
okay and then lastly we have our revised
revenue estimates this is sort of just
a one-page cheat sheet with fiscal year
21 having the anomalous receivable
removed and it just sums up all our
highs and lows ring
high and low ranges for 22 and 23
and then lastly we have our colorful
uh uh a colorful comparison
sheet on the left we have our fiscal
year 20 audited revenue for reference we
have fiscal year 21 plan
we then have the governor's and your
estimates which had pre-march data
we have those filled in and then we have
senate's
newest estimates that were done on
monday
that includes april data and it has our
hour
high and low that we just went over and
then we have this for 22 and 23.
we always like to know on this chart
it's more important to pay attention to
the percentages
growth for our low and high versus the
actual number because
those percentages growth vary based on
what your base is for fiscal year 21
and then same with 23 focus on the
percentages because it depends on what
your base is for
2022. this is a great job
why do you include this the wealth of
information
questions
you're going to send this to us aren't
you and i think
it sounds like chris is out of business
at the moment
by jen jensen it came in last night
you didn't get a
thanks i'm trying
in the meantime further questions from
the committee members on any of the
carol do you have anything to add or
devin
i don't think so i think melissa did a
great job
it's a good great team with the bra
add
since we're gonna do our actual revenue
estimates on june 8th
we'll have may data uh which would
probably be helpful
i guess i would just ask the department
of revenue
not to redo what they did but if there's
anything they see
when maze finalized that they think is
noteworthy that just pass it along to us
before as we do our january was it
eighth you said
no january not january
yes i'm sure we'll be with you on june
8th at least in the audience and we'll
be happy to share any
new or helpful information that we have
based on how
may performs on june 8 we'll have both
the lba and the
dre the lba could not be with us
today or will not be available next week
because they're finishing up
in the budget with the senate so that's
why
push this out to the eighth
representative me followed by
representative southwood
so i just went on spent the time i
should have been looking at my email
again
on going through all of the latest may
data
and i think that uh the dra has just
given us just everything that
uh that you could consider had changed
so far and we're pretty close to the end
of may at this point but
i i do agree that
that if there's another few surprises we
ought to know about it
thanks representative salisbury
uh thank you mr chairman a point of
order it seems obvious i guess but
they'll be taking our revenue estimates
subtracting the surplus statement if
most of it is negative
then that will give new figures that
hopefully would
match the finance committee's budget
i just haven't seen a chart before that
showed
the surplus statement subtracted that
way i bring it up because i'm still
finding many of my constituents are
reading on the paper about the
great revenues and they aren't really
understanding
and that's why they are electing you as
their state representative
so you could inform them yes i've been
trying
okay any other comments from any
committee members
then what we will do on the 8th
we'll have the dra and
along with the lba
will also have the final numbers from
the
senate on their budget with their
surplus statement so be we'll be able to
have that as a comparison
and then we'll consider all of this on
any further questions or comments mr
i'm sorry go ahead yeah shouldn't we
take a look
at the
department of safety estimates for the
i think that they had estimated
somewhat rosier but i haven't been able
to find
their month to on
on estimates of what the road toll was
going to come
come in at but as i recall them
they thought that we'd be closer than we
are now
to 2019 we are
uh the latest week came down to
to negative three percent but
two weeks before that it was still at
negative 10.
who was going to bring in all the other
agency heads
and review their revenues and see what's
changed
and if we need to make any changes
and on the eighth that may
but anything else if not i i'm
this is nothing else and thank everybody
for attending this morning
thank you and thanks
to the dra for another excellent job i
it was interesting information
and no meeting tomorrow mr chairman